[Music]
even though tuscan raiders show up in
star wars from the very beginning
and reappear throughout they remain
mysterious and poorly understood
who are they where do they come from
what do they want
and what do fans and casual viewers
alike need to know about them
the tuscan raiders appear first and most
memorably in a new hope
the sand people are initially presented
as fearsome savages
dangers to civilized people like luke
skywalker and his family
they roam the desert attacking and
pillaging the unsuspecting
when luke leaves the safety of his
homestead to search the jungle and waste
for his escape droid
r2d2 the raiders quickly overpower the
naive and unprepared young man
knocking him unconscious so they can
ransack his land speeder
luke is only saved when the mad hermit
ben kenobi
appears and scares away the raiders by
mimicking the call of the crate dragon
a beast they fear despite his ability to
scare them away
ben also warns luke the gentleman wastes
enough to be traveled lightly
of course if luke had died in the scene
he never would have blown up the death
star
fought darth vader become a jedi knight
and help defeat the empire
perhaps the trilogy would have centered
on leia organa luke's force-sensitive
sister instead
star wars mastermind george lucas
created the tuscan raiders in their
desert world to resemble the bedouins
tribes of arab nomads however it's
likely lucas's conception of the raiders
was
also influenced by the so-called savage
indians of john ford westerns
especially from the searchers which star
wars famously pays homage to
in the searchers comanche warriors
attacked the white settlers homestead
killing the family and burning the house
down while it's the imperial storm
troopers and not the tuscan raiders that
exterminate luke's family
lucas designed the scene in direct
homage to the scene from the searchers
in general lucas depicts the sand people
the way that ford depicts the comanche
brutal bloodthirsty and uncivilized in
terms of the name
tuscan sounds quite a bit like tuskegee
as in the tuskegee airmen
the first black us army airmen who
trained at the tuskegee army airfield in
alabama before flying in combat during
world war
ii lucas has long been interested in
their story even making a movie about
them with 2012's red tails
finally lucas was influenced by frank
herbert's sci-fi novel dune
which features nomad dwellers on the
desert planet arrakis
banthas are large trundling creatures
that resemble
elephants with huge droopy faces they
have curving tusks on the sides of their
heads shaped like cornucopias or perhaps
princess leia's hair buttons in a new
hope
the raiders used them as beasts of
burden lucas clearly liked the banthus
as he digitally inserted a lot more of
them in the special edition of return of
the jedi which features a herd of wild
banters roaming the tatooine desert they
are seen as jabba the hutt
transports luke han solo and company
across the dune sea to the pit of
kharkum to be slowly digested over a
thousand
years by the mighty sarlacc this is an
appropriate fate
since jabba had previously told han you
may have been a good smuggler but now
you're bantha fodder
digital panthers also appear briefly in
the phantom menace and attack of the
clones
chapter 9 of the mandalorian also
heavily features banthus
early in the episode the crate dragon a
huge worm-like creature
swallows one whole later a tuscan raider
brushes abanthus teeth and in the
climactic scene
a bantha is rigged with explosives and
used to bait the crate
the dragon swallows the bantha bomb and
the mandalorian detonates it causing
both animals to explode in a shower of
flame and flesh
in other news the aspca does not appear
to have a tatooine chapter
while it's true that banthas provide the
tuscan raiders with the means of
transportation across
tatooine's unforgiving terrain they
aren't merely beasts of burden
in fact every tuscan has a deep lifelong
connection with their bantha the
culture's initiation right which
typically takes place during youth
includes gifting the initiate a bantha
that matches their gender
when tuscans marry their banth is made
as well and in the unfortunate
circumstance that a bantha should die
before its rider
tradition calls for its remains to be
interred in a graveyard with sacred
meaning to the tuscan people
one of the star wars saga's strongest
points is the way in which
even incidental elements can be fully
fleshed out into stories of their own
and the bond between the banthas and the
sand people is a perfect example they
may have served as little more than a
brief
terrifying plot point in a new hope but
the hidden depths to their story
offer some of the franchise's most
compelling allegories
the tuscans have a cameo during the
episode 1 pod racing sequence and their
brief appearance in the movie echoes
their aggressive characterization from a
new hope
in the scene young anakin skywalker is
racing the villainous of bulba to gain
his freedom from slavery when the
tuscans attempt to disrupt the race
from their perch in the rocky hills
above the desert racetrack
the raiders take pot shots at the racers
with their long-barreled rifles
and celebrate when they hit anakin's pop
whether the tuscans are doing this for a
vicious sport or whether they feel they
are protecting their territory from
interlopers is never specified
either way the brief scene sets the
stage for the tuscan's longer appearance
in episode 2 a movie that seems to use
their established villainy to
justify their wholesale slaughter tuscan
raiders feature prominently in episode 2
attack of the clones in which they
kidnap and brutalize anakin's mother
shmi skywalker
anakin sneaks into their camp to
retrieve her but he is too late
and she dies in his arms in a fit of
vengeful rage he exterminates every
raider in the camp
including women and children this scene
appears to further equate the sand
people with cinematic native american
violence in lucas's vision
the kidnapping and slaughter and attack
of the clones again echoes the searchers
when the title characters discover
kidnapped white women in comanche tents
similar to the ones in episode 2. later
john wayne's character ethan
gleefully participates in a bloody
slaughter of the comanche which includes
scalping them
anakin also appears to relish his
butchery and tells padme that he simply
slaughtered them like
animals although lucas means to portray
anakin's killing as heartless a
significant step towards his embrace of
the dark
side the director's sympathies seem to
lie at least partially with anakin
anakin may be in the wrong but the
raiders are nevertheless depicted as
sub-creatures
undeserving of pity like most pop
culture properties that have been around
for decades
star wars has tried to keep up with the
times by reflecting social and cultural
changes
in particular the franchise has
attempted to be more diverse in its race
and gender representation
an effort that has resulted in backlash
from some fans who don't care
for change the mandalorian has been part
of this effort
both with its casting and behind the
camera it even attempts a makeover of
the tuscan raiders by representing them
as a less
overtly aggressive and more complex
culture the more complex portrait of the
sand people of the mandalorian
debuts in chapter five of season one
when another character implies that the
tuscans are filth
who bother the locals the mandalorian
responds
tuscans think they're the locals
everyone else is just trespassing
he then peacefully attains passage
through their land by negotiating with
them in their sign language
this is the first notion anywhere in
film star wars that raiders have a
language
let alone one that allows them to
communicate with other peoples language
is one of the most important markers of
civilization
and this episode presents it as a
feature of the tuscans who are no longer
depicted
as the backward savages of previous eras
after their cameo in chapter 5 of the
mandalorian the tuscans return in the
action-packed season 2 opener in an even
more vital role
in this episode the mandalorian enlists
their help to kill a crate dragon this
quest returns full circle to the saga's
introduction of the sand people in a new
hope when ben kenobi's crate noises
frighten them away from luke
but this time we see the actual beast
and quickly understand why the sand
people as well as the human settlers of
the frontier town
maz pelgo fear it consistent with the
mistrust dramatized between settlers and
natives in so many westerns the human
settlers in mos palgo are reluctant to
trust the sand people
until the mandalorian broke as a
tentative piece naturally
the mandalorian is fluent in two
separate dialects of tuscan
one silent one spoken and so is able to
explain that the nomads are not only
capable
and rational but also honorable people
who keep their word
working together the humans and tuscans
defeat their common enemy of course many
of the sand people die in the cause
while virtually all the humans walk away
unscathed
tuscan raiders may have come a long way
in the star wars universe but evidently
they are still expendable not much about
tuscan culture is seen or discussed in
the star wars movies but as with just
about any other species that's even so
much as glimpsed in the background of
the scene there's a deep well of
information about the raiders that star
wars fans can glean from a variety of
sources
indigenous to tatooine the tuscan
raiders not only view
outsiders with deep and often violent
mistrust but they regard natural
resources
particularly water with a spiritual
level of respect
it's this component of the tuscan belief
system that led them to raid moisture
farms and attack
travelers who wandered too close to the
planet's scarce natural wells
of course all any long time star wars
fan wants to know about the tuscan
raiders is what they look like under
their masks
a question that seems unlikely to ever
be answered in canonical media the
tuscans have an almost religious
aversion to removing them
only showing their faces during life
milestones such as their wedding night
the tuscan raiders speak using a
combination of vocal speech
and sign language and as we see in the
mandalorian our hero is well versed in
both forms
what casual viewers may not realize
however is that tuscan sign language is
real
and it was developed by actor troy
kotzer a mandalorian actor who is deaf
and developed the language to look as
little like american sign language as
possible
mandalorian viewers caught a good
glimpse of kotzer's work during the
season 2 episode the marshall
in which mando and cobb vanth team up
with the tuscan tribe to kill a crate
dragon that's been plaguing the tatooine
outpost of moss palgo
in late 1977 and early 1978 the first
year after the original film's release
star wars sold
100 million dollars worth of toys
industry-wide
sales are up by almost eight percent
most of the increase attributable to the
space toys craze
22 million figures per year
since then star wars toy merchandising
has become a billion dollar industry
still thriving today with new action
figures funko pops
and lego sets introduced regularly there
are even books and documentaries devoted
to the creation and selling of the toys
as well as many volumes and sites
cataloging them george lucas famously
negotiated the rights to the star wars
sequels from 20th century fox
partially so he could have the
merchandising rights as well one cynical
way of explaining the sheer number of
new characters and ships for each new
movie is by considering how many new
toys lucas could peddle along with their
more diminutive fellow tatooine dwellers
the jawas the sand people as they were
then known
were among the first dozen figures to
kick off the global merchandising
phenomenon
there have been many iterations of the
figures since some now going by their
proper tuscan rated designation
the original vintage action figure now a
collector's item can be had for hundreds
of dollars on ebay
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star wars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one